so I have to talk to you about this
because bonus songs on the 25th inspired
by like this you only got these song
There are songs that you had recorded
like in your live or not recorded but
like just played and there were fans
that actually recorded CU you didn't
remember them and you actually found a
fan you go to is his name Allan yeah
this is the most incredible story tell
everybody so I've always been prolific
but I've never written anything down and
so I lose songs all the time and so it
was the dawn of the internet so I'd get
on there on some list serve I'd be like
does anybody have a song called Jessica
that I sang once at a cafe in Toronto
and this guy would always write back and
go yeah I have that bootleg and yes I
have that one and yes I have that one I
was like do you want a job so I ended up
hiring him he's worked for me since like
94 or something like that
[Music]
incredible
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home